you think that i will always love you is
one of the three best songs ever written
the other two being hallelujah leonard
cohen and um a case of you joni mitchell
the three best songs ever written yeah
if we keep going we do someone saved my
life tonight
yeah by elton john too
and and gosh maybe yesterday yeah i was
thinking paul simon the boxer too you
ever heard the twins sing simon and
garfunkel no
they do sound a silence and it's yeah
tim and phil tim and phil you [ __ ]
guys are super talented i mean i watched
some of these performances they you
really are
i want to hear it
if i said to you without rehearsal
without anything you're obviously not
planning to do that if i said just do a
little verse or something or could you
do it or do you need to like do tons of
preparation oh maybe it could be a
little piece of it yeah do a little
piece in a few seconds why not yeah a
little piece of it
go ahead i want to hear it yeah mess it
up i don't even care like this one sound
at six o'clock in the morning but
pretend it's like a rehearsal or
something
and you're just [ __ ] around yeah
let's try it
just a piece of it all right
hello darkness my old friend
i've come to talk with you again
because a vision softly creeping
left it seeds while i was sleeping
and the vision
that was planted in my brain
still remains
within the sound
[Music]
you know what's great this is why i
think i love talking to musicians
within 30 seconds
he gave me goosebumps and tears what
other art form can do that beside music
you know it's like a super power in it
yeah
yeah